hi my name is ben ajiyobi and i am a
data scientist at depop
and i primarily focus on
the ranking team
hi i'm david hypes i'm a data scientist
with depops as well and i work within
the martech team um yeah specializing in
marketing technology and do a lot of
work on text clustering
attribution so
so i apologize in advance i've had a
cold the last few days so if i if i
cough or sneeze please you know
i apologize so uh we're here to talk
about uh societal bias in
state-of-the-art and i'll play transport
learning and when we say
state-of-the-art uh this is a few years
uh so you know it's it's recent
um
yeah we've got a bit of a warning say we
use um some language models to generate
text and it is you know artificially
generated and it may be offensive or
upsetting and we do not uh wish to
offend and obviously these you know
what's contained in this text is not our
our our feelings
and our thoughts
so yeah what is bias
and so bias is an inclination or
prejudice or against one person or a
group in a way that's considered uh
unfair generally
um
and
harm is the negative sort of impact of
bias so it's when a system allocates
always holds a certain opportunity or a
resource
to a particular group or reinforces
subordination of uh groups along the our
lines of identity
so yeah i'm just going to go through a
few sources of bias and first of all
we've got data biases um reporting bias
i mean this one's really quite an
obvious one uh over the last
sort of 200 years it's been primarily
been sort of middle-aged very rich white
people recording history um
and
that that
you know comes through uh in all of the
uh
and all of the data that we train our
language models on
selection bias as well when you select
uh samples that um
don't contain
the the sort of general uh understanding
of of the of the group
uh historical industrial injustices so
in the past we'd have thought things are
actually morally correct uh that are now
morally wrong and they've been recorded
and we're again training our models on
those
an implicit bias i'm just so i'm just to
go for a couple implicit biases when
you're making an assumption based on
your own sort of your own understanding
and your own your own memory
um and again uh out group
homogeneity bias stereotyping basically
you see as people outside of your group
as less alike than those inside your
group
and you want to move to the next slide
and then you've got interpretation
biases i'm just going to go so
confirmation bias for example
um you're going to look for uh patterns
uh and information that confirms what
you believe already
um as a
as a researcher you come up with a
hypothesis and there are you know there
are ways to get around these sort of
piece by the the confirmation bias
really
if you want to get to the next slide and
that is
um yeah and
another problem here with experimental
advice the outcome of the experiment
tends to be biased towards the result
expected and
so
there's this i think these slides are
going to be made available afterwards so
if you want to look at a few others then
then they're there
um
cool so
a lot of you would have heard of this
old riddle before a father and son are
in a horrible car crash that kills the
dad
the son is rushed to the hospital just
about he's about to have the operation
he uh the surgeon says i can't operate
uh that boy is my son now who do you
expect that
the surgeon or doctor to be in this case
and if you get to the next slide
um so it was actually a boston
university study
and the majority of respondents um
including males females uh all sorts of
groups and didn't actually realize that
the doctor was female
um and just made the assumption or or
tried tried to find ways to to sort of
uh to prove that or to prove or say that
it wasn't a woman that was actually
operating or trying to operate in this
case and so that's very old a lot of
people would heard of it but it's you
know it's quite an important one
next up
so we're going to go through some
examples of bias here um first of all
within machine translation again an old
example and but very important one uh
previously with google translate you
could use to translate sentences from
one language to another and back again
and this is a really good example of the
older model that google were using in
which you translate the sentence here as
a nurse she is a doctor into hungarian
unfortunately i don't speak hungarian so
i can't i can't pronounce this
and then back again it actually
translates it as she's a nurse and he is
a doctor
it's clearly using uh sort of a bias
within with within the data that's been
trained to uh reallocate the gender
um
here of the of the nurse and the doctor
and next slide
so yeah this can also be seen within
language models on the right hand side
you've got
here's a doctor and she is a doctor and
and and you can see that that his doctor
is is more likely within this model and
again within co-reference resolution the
same problem um he is related to doctor
more often than she is related
and next slide
and within word embeddings um say for
example fast text and bottles words deck
whatever um you can see again that uh
if you project the uh gender-specific
gender-neutral words along a he she
plane you can see that certain words are
relate you know they're they're more
closely correlated to to the sort of the
male than the female and here you can
see that the gender was in sorry in the
top
graph you can see the gender words below
um and then above words that have no
gender but they've been correlated with
um so you can see that you know um
the females are more likely to uh
correlate with dances and dress and
beautiful and males journeyman
uh cocky uh guru and so on
and again you can see this within uh
within relations within embeddings so
man minus woman is
very similar to computer programmer and
homemaker and ben's going to go on to
that a bit later as well if you want to
move to the next slide
um so gpt2 allows you to generate text
um and you know there's obviously gpt
threes out now um and has improved upon
but uh these are some examples of a
prompt and then the generated text
afterwards now i'll let you go through
these at your own leisure but clearly uh
there are there are biases within this
data
next up
again hate speech detection uh so this
was a leading cnn um and it was shown
that uh
hate speech detection on social media
led to a one and a half times higher
likelihood of tweets written by african
americans as being flagged as offensive
this is actually uh less down to a
database and more down to an annotation
bias and there's insensitivity
but obviously it's gonna it's gonna have
a clear negative harm that it's gonna
have sorry it's gonna have a harm uh on
the people it's it's affecting
next up
so what we're focusing on in this talk
mainly is is bias within the corporate
bias within data so you've got to go
through some uh common uh corporate used
for
large pre-trained language models but
corpus is one of them it's used by bert
and so on um it's a collection of
scanned in books
um the genre is sort of skewed towards
romance and fantasy includes 18 plus
content and terms like alpha female
sorry alpha male and submissive female
and there's also a huge religious
representation that's skewed towards
christianity and a lot of the authors
sorry some of the authors contributed
way more books than than than the others
so this leads to led to leads to if you
train a model uh using this data without
uh trying to clean it up first a skewed
religious representation skewed genres
and the potential harmful gender
stereotypes next slide
cc news collection of news articles uh
again like there's a
huge group a huge selection of sort of
sources for these articles but we're not
sure what political leanings of these
sources are
um
and these stories range from like beauty
pageants through to petty and serious
crime so you can see like immediately
there's going to be little political
skews would be racial stereotyping
there's going to be socio-economic
stereotyping
um
and gender stereotypes as well
next up
c4 so this is a cleaned up version of
common cruel um
this has uh bad words removed um using a
replay dirty naughty obscene and
otherwise bad words on github
um but again this is you know if that
list isn't updated frequently enough
you're gonna have
you're going to have certain words that
are going to be missed
and language detection models then used
to filter that out but
that that kind of leads to a lack of
minority ethnic english
samples within within that
and there's also the potential for
harmful racial stereotypes in there as
well
next up
uh wikipedia now this is a recent paper
that was published was missed
categorized gender notability and then
quality in on wikipedia so it showed
that um
that certain uh articles or articles
written by women are about women were
more likely to be uh suggested for
deletion
um than days written by or about men and
which is awful and obviously that's
going to lead to inherent gender
inequality
and yeah wikipedia is used in so many
models uh used to train so many things
next up
so we've got a little try it yourself uh
if you go to
huggingface.com you can actually select
the model and in this case it's just
basic but uncased
you can then add type in a sentence and
use mask for it to generate a token
and so here we've got an example uh i
read the sentence i got a new job as
mask
and the model suggested waitress nurse
teacher made and model now three of
those are on a gender neutral
um and you can see that there's there
are stereotypes that you know there's
bias that's passed through this this
model and it's suggested these
particular tokens
if you then put in steve got a new job
as a
then you get suggested mechanic
bartender teacher
waiter and salesman
so yeah you can clearly see that there's
bias within this otherwise it would
suggest similar jobs
um next step
so this is a much much worse one if you
put christians are generally masks to
other people you get compared closer
attracted hostile opposed to
um and then if you put in muslims
generally masked to other people you get
inferior which is mad
um compared opposed hostile and related
and you can see that this this these the
the data the biases within these these
corpora and therefore these models can
have a really really negative impact uh
and cause quite a lot of harm
so next up we have uh
ben he's going to just cover how to
address bias within these models
thanks david uh yeah so
i just wanted to
say that i've only got 10 minutes left
so i'm going to go through the process
fairly quickly but if you i've linked
all the papers i reference and i
encourage you to read
all the papers because there's quite
interesting work in this area going and
there are lots of interesting problems
to solve
so in this particular area we're
focusing on um attention models for nlp
that have been pre-trained for the
purpose of fine-tuning later um for
those who don't really know much about
this process the idea is that you have a
very large neural network that you
pre-train on some
pre-training tasks such as word masking
as david described previously or a
sentence classification with the idea
that the model
encapsulates information from the
statistics of the text in these large
corpora
uh and then this model is then saved and
can be later fine-tuned to any
particular task that you have a
particular data set for so this is kind
of an element of transfer learning in a
sense um where the fine-tuning task
could be to classify sentiment of
particular text and because the
pre-trained model has accumulated these
nuanced understanding of text it is in a
better position than starting from zero
for the classification task
so
as david mentioned there's a lot of
inherent biases in these these models
and there have been rel there have been
quite a few approaches taken to mitigate
these biases
so these are a couple that i mentioned
uh particularly for the pre-training
stage so data augmentation involves
wherever a gendered word like he or she
grandmother grandfather is found within
the corpora a
counterfactual alternative is made with
the uh opposing gender word so he then
copied with a she replacement
um this is in effect kind of
neutralizing the bias as all bias
gendered words are kind of associated
with the same different tokens
um the bias aware objective function
below is actually a slightly differing
but similar feature where um
gendered counterfactual sequences are
inputted into the model at the same time
and a dual objective function is trained
where one objective is to train the
particular task at hand in this case a
sentiment classifier and the other
objective is trying to minimize the
variance between the differences in
these two outputs the idea being that
the probability of a negative positive
sentiment for he is a lifelong bachelor
and she is a lifelong bachelorette
should be exactly the same in the equal
world
so these problems suffer from a
effectively a resource issue the
pre-training stage is really really
resource intensive and is very very
expensive and so these creating
experiments on top of these strategies
is not really practical for most people
gpt3
incidentally cost 12 million dollars
just to train once uh so you can see
that it's not practical kind of line of
attack
so here are some examples where um
they actually tried to address a bias in
the model that has um
already been pre-trained and so we see
on the paper here man is to computer
program as woman is the homemaker
devising word embeddings this is
actually a really interesting seminal
paper that has a very amazing approach
to actually quantify what gender bias
means in embeddings and then a half
decent attempt at extracting uh gender
bias so the idea was that um the
embeddings that are created from the uh
encoder of a transformer are projected
into a subspace via pca and the idea is
that you're very selective on the words
you use to create this bias subspace so
you use words that's a different meaning
only by gender
so these are for example man or woman or
girl boy
he she
and when you
project these tokens into the pca
subspace uh the principal component
the first one explains the missed
variant should uh encapsulate that
gender direction
and the strategy that this paper
employed was to ensure that all
gen gender-neutral tokens are actually
equidistant inside this direction so
this so the word for example um
homemaker should be equidistant between
man and woman in this subspace
and they applied a function that
transformed the embedding so that when
they were projected into the subspace
they would be equidistant
and this was quite a clever form of
eliminating that particular gender
direction
the paper on the right learning gender
neutral word embeddings
this actually
does involve pre-training but it
actually um involves
manipulating the embedding itself
afterwards so the idea was that they
manipulated the objective function of
the neural network so that
the gender information was primarily
focused into one particular element of
the embeddings in the neural network
typically
the information is kind of
allocated where it's most needed for the
actual task at hand in an aura network
but in this case it's focused into one
particular kind of
element in that embedding and the idea
is that once the
training phase is completed you can then
simply delete or null that one element
that encapsulates gender effectively
making the the model gender blind in a
sense
um
however
there has been a recent paper lipstick
on a pick d biasing
up systematic gender biases in word
embeddings but do not remove them
so this was a recent paper that
discovered that the
although these papers were very
effective in eliminating bias in a
particular direction under that
definition
they don't actually eliminate bias as a
whole in the model
this is because bias is very nuanced
matter and it's it's it's very hard to
define and create a real
definition of what
gender bias actually is in the model
um so they show that the
by eliminating the principle the first
principle component direction of gender
bias in your embedding space
um you're only removing one component of
gender bias but there's several other
remain and there are other principal
components out there that include that
gender bias information
and for example
to give you a concrete example if you
take the word nurse
and you
you transform it so there's a distance
between man and woman that has removed
one dimension of bias however you
the word nurse may be close to the word
feminine or the word homemaker
and that by association allows the model
to recreate the gender bias that is
embedded in the neural network
and this paper demonstrates this by
applying the
the neighborhood
dimensionality production algorithm
t-sne to show that the
words that are uh gendered uh separate
when this algorithm is applied to them
before and after these de-biasing
strategies are employed so you can see
here the information is can be
completely reconstructed and the bias is
still inherent in the model even after
these biasing strategies
so
this was a recent paper that
attempts to
address these limitations of the
previous strategies uh it is called
iterative null space projection
uh so this is the general uh algorithm
outline um and it involves effectively
training a classifier on the embed on
the gendered embeddings in attempt to
remove gender bias and i'll explain each
step of this algorithm in the next slide
but the paper is linked if you'd like to
read in detail more about the strategy
but so this strategy begins first by
creating that gendered subspace so on
the right hand side here we have an
illustration of what i mean by this
gendered subspace so you can see in
green i've included those gendered words
i mentioned previously that were
actually used to construct this subspace
hershey female his he male
and you can see in red indicates the
first principle component that explains
the largest
variation in this data which also
correlates to the biggest gender
direction
and once we have done that we then
project all of the other tokens
embeddings from our vocabulary into this
subspace and as a result you can see
that several words tanning modelling
homemaker or chief genius and captain
they
tend towards either polarity of this
direction some more to female and some
more to male
and this shows that these words are bias
sensitive tokens and this is a very
effective way of accumulating uh tokens
that have this biosensitivity in either
direction
and so the way what sorry the way what
we do next is uh once we've found these
sets of words and we'll normally have a
cut-off limit we'll say okay the words
that are tending towards female will
assign that label a concrete label or
female and the words that tend towards
male we assign that concrete label of
male and as in a in effect we
turn the problem into a classification
problem
so now we have the word embeddings on
the left with their labels of gender
and then we have a linear classifier
with these particular weights and this
classifier is then tasked with
discovering the decision boundary that
most effectively uh discriminates
between the female and male sensitive
words
and this uh once we have accumulated
this what you can now say is that this
linear classifier
the weights encapsulate the gender
information uh from the actual
embeddings themselves
and here comes the the part where we
apply the null space projection so the
idea of null space projection
is that uh you can discover a matrix
where given the dot product with the
embeddings uh it projects the um
projects the matrix into the null space
of the classifier weights
so what this means in practice is that
the uh the embeddings we see on the
right hand side
uh are projected onto that decision
boundary given this null space
projection
matrix and this makes the classifier no
longer able to actually classify whether
the
the device sensitive tokens are male or
female
and what we have here is is actually
quite a clever strategy for surgically
removing
the gendered words gendered information
from the embeddings as it was discovered
by the classifier
now the actual algorithm a cell itself
does this in an iterative manner
in a kind of a cumulative way where once
we have discovered um this our null
space projection matrix we then
train a new classifier on this nullified
embedding
new embedding um to just to discover a
new way of classifying these um gender
differences and this is because there
are multiple decision boundaries that
could exist in the dimensionality for
classifying male or female and so by
introducing really uh applying our
approach we are effectively removing
more and more of the
information that encodes the bias in the
embedding
uh and at the end of our process we are
now left with our null space projection
which is the product of all previously
created projections in each iteration
and what this effect means is now we can
take any uh word embedding and apply the
dot product with our projection and this
creates an embedding that really
removes the gender bias
because it from this embedding a
classifier at least a linear classifier
could no longer predict the gender of
the embedding uh i should state that
this is a linear guarding function the
limitation of this approach is that a
non-linear function could still recreate
the um
recreate the gender potentially
so here how it's made in practice is
that we formalize a encoder as
a transformer as an encoder section
that gives an output which is then
applied to the uh the weights
uh which is considered to be the last
layer of the um
of the model so this is normally just
one linear layer
uh in our case we apply the linear
guarding function g over the encoding
over the output of the encoding block
such that the weights no longer has kind
of uh access to the gender bias
information in the word and it won't
influence inputs
however one limitation of this is that
the linear guiding function has reduced
the rank of the encoder output which
could hurt the performance of the actual
model as a whole and so what they do is
in their paper they freeze the weights
of the encoder and apply and do a bit
more of continued so they re retrain the
model again on the task but this time
only changing the weights of w so that
now w is tuned to the output of g rather
than just the encoding
so this is the um
this is the general strategy uh i'm just
going to quickly show you i'm a i am
conscious that i run out of time but i
have actually a worked example of this
um of this process so here we actually
take the burt language model
and um
it's the task of the model is to predict
the mast uh mass word inside a sequence
and in this particular case i'm
extracting the uh embeddings from the
first encoder layer as that was the one
that saw at least for me had the best
output in this particular scenario
so from here we can see we're generating
our biosensitive tokens these are for
male these are for female and these are
some neutral ones we made
and here we can see that applying t
sneeze who are are
are projected
embeddings we can see that they're very
linear separable for
female and male by having applied an old
projection to them t-sne is no longer
able to just to distinguish the two uh
and once we feed this
null this guarded embedding back into
the network and run it through the
language model we can now see the output
has changed so here we have an example
people thought she he was very something
during the meeting in an unguarded
scenario where we don't touch the neural
network uh the first sentence people
shot she was thought she was very
beautiful during the meeting
and people thought he was very popular
during the meeting this now changes once
we apply the guarding output to that one
layer in the encoder so people thought
she was very quiet during the meeting
people thought he was very quiet during
the meeting so we can see this is
actually influenced the the behavior of
the model um towards reducing the gender
bias
i will say we will be sharing these
codes so you can play around with this
if you would like um i would say as well
this is not a complete solution
mitigating gender bias in these in these
um these models is extremely difficult
and there is lots of work still to be
done not only with
actually removing it but also measuring
it
i realized i've gone over time
uh no uh i think uh we we you completed
just some time like there was a mishap
from our side so i would like to
apologize again for the mishap
uh but yeah we do have questions for you
uh
uh let me let me start uh so there's a
question by jessica uh the question goes
like how can we be sure that in the
post-training step
the one done after the guarding the
embeddings we do not just relearn the
bias yeah that's that's a really good
question i think um i suppose in their
particular scenario um they're hoping
that the
the guarding function
has already removed the information and
so
the retraining will only perform only
improve performance on the model but
it is possible and also because the last
layer is linear and only linear and
we're doing a linear guarding function i
hope with the hope is that
the linear layer won't be able to
actually
relearn that bias
so it's very important that last layer
is linear
i think also the uh when you're
fine-tuning you're just going to have to
make sure that the data that the extra
data that you're providing has no bias
in it and
you know so it doesn't then
learn uh the bias from your data
since you've removed it from the
pre-trained model yeah
okay we have a question here uh yeah uh
david can you see the question
yep so how does null space projection
ensure that gender words not present in
the initial list do not lose their
aspect in their encoding
uh in german most professions come in a
female and male version version
as far as i understand these would all
lose their gender information if not
present in the list of frozen words
that is a very good question and
there's actually a second paper that
addresses this exact question
called autoregressive and actually i'll
send a link to the paper as well on the
slack but it's called auto aggressive
iterative null space protection
and
they
slightly change the actual
strategy of using the guiding function
such that they apply a a weight to the
guarding function so how sorry to the um
to the output of the of the guarded
network i guess um
such that if it sees tokens that aren't
so
gender
sensitive or should not be augmented in
the gender way then it will kind of
create a parameter to offset the
contribution of the guarding function to
the model's output but that was a um
that was a paper written after the one i
mentioned and uh it actually
they actually talk about the exact
scenario you mentioned where professions
are associated with the gender and that
is useful
um
i'm sorry i have not so much professions
but um
yes these these important these
important uh associations are addressed
in their evaluation as well
awesome thank you
um so that brings us the time and
let me just
stop recording